guten morgen europa es ist kurz nach
acht an der mosel im kleinen
luxemburgischen ort schengen 560
einwohner und sehr viele rebstöcker wenn
die arbeiter morgens zum weinberg kommen
haben sie eine nur zehnminütige fahrt
hinter sich die sich anhört wie eine
kleine weltreise frankreich und
deutschland liegen gleich um die ecke
grenzkontrollen gibt es aber keine mehr
und das liegt an einem abkommen das hier
vor mehr als 30 jahren geschlossen wurde
die urkunde des sogenannten schengener
abkommens ist in einem kleinen museum
ausgestellt es steht für ein europa ohne
schlagbäume toni songs mit seiner
familie aus shanghai hier
er arbeitet als it spezialist in
stuttgart und ist mit dem auto hierher
gefahren um seiner familie ein symbol
europas zu zeigen das ist absolut
einzigartig
besonders für uns mit einem chinesischen
pass früher vor dem schengener abkommen
mussten chinesen immer für jedes
einzelne land in europa ein visum
beantragen
jetzt brauchen wir nur ein einziges
visum und können ganz viele staaten
besuchen
das ist ein unglaubliches gefühl vor dem
museum eine türkische reisegruppe gerade
für die türkei die seit jahren versucht
mitglied der europäischen union zu
werden hat schengen einen magischen
klang millionen türken arbeiten in der
eu und wissen also was es heißt ein
visum für den sogenannten schengen-raum
zu beantragen
für die touristen ein höhepunkt ihrer
kleinen europareise sein name den wir
seit jahren kennen aber nicht touristen
wissen nichts über diesen hort ich will
ihnen zeigen dass schengen nicht der
name eines visums ist sondern ein ort
dem kleinen ort sieht man seine große
bedeutung kaum an schengen ist ein stück
gelebtes europa roger weber war
jahrelang bürgermeister und es besonders
stolz auf die kulturelle vielfalt seines
dorfes
er führt uns ins café deal die
dorfkneipen die bedienung ist eine
portugiesin unter den gästen
deutsche und franzosen
damit haben wir keine probleme überhaupt
kein problem aber probleme könnte es
geben wenn die grenzkontrollen innerhalb
europas verschärft werden wenn das
schengen abkommen wegen der millionen
flüchtlinge die zurzeit nach europa
einreisen außer kraft gesetzt werden
sollte darunter würden auch die schengen
erleiden allen voran die spedition ein
job ja rein hat 77 lkw bier von schengen
haus nach ganz europa schickt
so wie das jetzt aufgebaut dies hat er
damit zu tun dass einmal die grenzen
abgeschafft wurde und jeder hat dann
sein geschäft so aufgebaut und jeder
seine leute auch so eingestellt damit
man eigentlich wirtschaftlichen druck
arbeiten kann und man beschäftigte auf
gegen diese ecke danach über 200 leuten
die meisten seiner mitarbeiter wohnen
gar nicht in luxemburg und kommen aus
frankreich oder deutschland
sie fahren jeden morgen über die grenze
das ganze unternehmen wäre in gefahr
sollten schärfere grenzkontrollen
eingeführt werden
das ganze wir sehen ja auch das was ich
da findest du sie landen ich meine leute
müssten auch müssten das ist ganz
wichtig vielleicht findet man aber einen
anderen weg da jetzt nicht kaputt nach
nicht nur weil wir hier in lege meine
chancen sind aber ich spreche auch für
all die anderen oder man sollte schon so
zusammensetzen und nicht all die arbeit
die jetzt geleistet wird auch von
unserer politik also das nicht aufs
spiel setzen wieder alles kaputt machen
das wäre das ende und dann wird es eine
autobahn nahe des ortes erstmals
ständige kontrollen geben die fernstraße
wurde erst nach dem schengen-abkommen
fertiggestellt ganz ohne schlagbäume und
ohne
grenzanlagen